Y ahí pienso que bloque ten capacidad para ser
1 1 actor político que unas segmentos muy diferentes
en la sociedad de que nos explican
en esa, en ese esquema tan clásico que es derecha izquierda,
pienso que también muy todo lo que está pasando en el Mundo,
pues cada vez entra más ese debate en que a defensa
a soberanía, tengas 1 estado o no,
es 1 elemento de progreso eh fundamental
y y donde no estemos ahí moito
vamos moito hay que trabajar,
aunque eso hay que
eh, aquí nos conseguimos
superar 1 crisis política muy importante,
conseguimos también no
eh mantener 1 tradición,
pero al mismo tiempo
saber leer los cambios que se están
produciendo en las sociedades,
saber conectar con eh, ser acciones distintas
y serar 1,
yo creo que 1 Marco que es muy importante para ovenega,
que que se sea considerado
por sectores sociales
muy amplios como alternativa frente o PP
como alternativa real,
y esto eh por lo menos um
diría que en los últimos 20 años no Han pasado a no país
como mínimo
y que nos da 1 posibilidad muy grande de vamos
de
de poder transformar los límites que tengo Marco no porque
Marco tiene límites,
pero en fin, hay 1 amarse de mellora
grande je je je je,
o a situación que tenemos aquí es muy muy muy grave,
hay 1 elemento que pienso que importante se
proyectado a futuro